hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the Morphy
saga and if you are just joining us in
the morphe saga we haven't gotten very
far this is only the third video in the
saga so if you want to check it out from
the from the beginning the first two
will be the first thing you will see in
the description below so check it out if
you're just tuning in so this is the
second game of the match that we that we
mentioned Paul Morphy versus a Hungarian
mastery on Jakob Blumenthal and that we
already saw how morphe one that very
nice game and here's the second game
morphe again has the white pieces and
there is an explanation to this which we
will discuss at the end of the game and
also i've prepared a nice photo of this
matchup
let me just fetch it sorry let me just
find it okay here it is
there we go it's it's a bit small so let
me just enlarge it it's not from this
exact match as this is from 1958 and
this match that we are now covering is
from 1950 but just we get in the mood as
we don't have any other photo of the two
of them playing so now let's just enjoy
that the two gentlemen at the board it's
one of the games were more he had the
black pieces obviously now that being
said let's check it out so this game
morphe also opens with efore but here a
Leventhal opens with c5 so he goes for
the Sicilian defense and the more he
goes for f4 which is today known as the
grand prix attack against the Sicilian
in those days morphe just didn't want to
develop his night before playing the EDF
pawn so why would why would he do such a
thing something that's well known since
since the Philidor came up with those
ideas and sorry about that we have E 6
by black preparing d5 so fight fighting
for the center Knight to f3 and now d5
with eek a person d5e captures and e5
and d4 morphe also fights for the center
we have Bishop to g4 now pinning the
knight and Bishop to e2 and it's
interesting to note that this position
reached and moved six has never again
been repeated in chess history well in
in tournament games
so we've bushel characters nf3 Bishop
characters in the 90 to f6 continuing
development of Morphy castles and Bishop
to e7 Leventhal prepares the castle as
well Bishop to e3
now with ideas of capturing and c5 and
here a modern player would most likely
just Castle and if and if captures
gunite a sex go after the pawn this way
but Leventhal decided to trade in the
center right away which is a bit
unprincipled breaking the tension but
but okay with Bishop captures on d4 and
now Leventhal castles we have Knight to
c3 and here nice the c6
going for more fees Bishop and now in
more if he has to decide whether he
wants to keep the bishop pair like
bishop f2 let's ad for an ID b5 and
played this game where he would go
probably a four and then if a six he
could read maneuver the night inter
again be at the c-4 square or he wants
to trade the deep one for the beep on
and this is what morphe goes for he
plays Bishop captures on f6 Bishop
captures we have Knight captures on d5
now Bishop captures and beat you and
then our rook the b1 so now if you
didn't have this check then you would
also lose the b7 pawn so there should be
four check first King to h1 and now rook
to b8 which makes sense you want to get
your rook away from this diagonal also
you do not want to lose the b7 point so
Ruby eight perfectly good move and now
c3 kicking away the bishop also taking
away two very important squares from the
from the night here and also it opens up
some diagonals for the Queen if needed
so this should back the c5 and now f5
now more if he wants to play f6 and
start an attack against the black King
so we have Queen to h4 now long and tall
prepares a little trap now if more if he
does go for f6 then Bishop d6 is very
strong for him if you go g3 then just
Bishop captures the H pawn is pinned so
you would have to go 97 check and here
you would just have to give back that
pawn and it would actually be black was
better here up upon so instead more if
he goes g3 right away now Bishop to b6
makes a little sense so Queen to g5 and
only now f6 by morphine now while g6 is
is a perfectly fine move Leventhal
the decides that he's gonna give up the
g-seven pony and he's gonna start with
with his own attack so he goes Knights
the e5 Murphy captures of course in g7
it's it's a must play so F captors and
g7 attacks the rook and now rook F to d8
and here okay it so it's a strong
position for black perhaps the the
knight cannot move you have ideas like
rook to d6 bringing the rook over the
attack we are look to h6 it could be
very strong
however Morphy has a also a very strong
move here so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this very strong
move while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as it's
not an easy move to find but it is the
engine stop recommendation and Morphy
plated Bishop to e4 so congratulations
to everyone who found it
Bishop the e4 now with the idea that he
wants to play rook to f5 and now if you
continue with the relax rook d6 you want
to shoot the rook into the attack rook
f5 now you pick up the pawn you defend
the night
now comes look the b5 and here you see
some problems the bishop is well the
bishop doesn't have a good square since
the rook just blocked it and if if the
bishop is is gone then you have ideas
like night the Knights the e7 check open
up our discovery to the rook Queen
captures rook all sorts of ideas become
possible so let's say Bishop a3 rook a5
you still go after the bishop and then
now there is not much to be done if you
defend it just row captures and you
cannot recapture because if you
recapture then 97 check King moves and
then just Queen Queen picks up the rook
and you are up a bishop or or up a piece
so brush up the e4 incredibly strong
so Leventhal of course in expecting of
this rook tothe rooked fi movie goes
Queen to g7 and grabs that pawn now the
night is already defended but now Queen
to h5 buy more fee we have looked at
these six now preparing rook to h6
but here more if we just plays bunch of
characters on h7 with check and now the
problem is if you capture then you put
then you
have Queen chapters on e5 and here
you're just lost
Knight to f6 check is coming and there's
not much to be done here you would have
to you would have to give up the the
rook but it doesn't help you because
either you can capture hero you can
capture the be a crook with the check
there is just not not much to be done
here so after Bishop captures an h7 we
have kink the f8 by Lowenthal and the
now Bishop back to e4 we have looked at
h6 peeking back more if his Queen Queen
to f7 now
sorry f5 attacking f7 and now comes
Queen captures and g3 so let me tell
wins back at the pawn but Murphy says
it's not a problem just rugby to the h2
point is now guarded there's no mate
and here xi all should go for Queen to
h3 offer a queen trade and play go into
the endgame but seems like Lowenthal
either did not quite yet fully grasp the
extent of more fees more fee skills he
was hooked
I ate instead and this allows more fee
for for a very nice trick here more free
plays Knight to f6 he goes after the
rope first and after the rook moves now
well now morphic could have gone a bit
differently here more fee this article
looked rook to g2 which makes sense if
the Queen moves roped roof to g8 pretty
much finishes the game but he allows 11
thought to sacrifice the Queen what he
should have done is just Knight d7 check
and this makes perfect sense since the
knight cannot capture due to the
checkmate on f7 and if you move the King
then it's just a free Bishop Knight
captures on c5 and after rook f6 going
after going after the Queen now you have
rook captures on b7 with check King f8
and now again
Knight the e6 and here here comes the
tricky part after F captures and e6 now
you capture the Queen now you give up
the Queen rook captures rook captures
the King has to move King gate and now
you recapture the Queen and it's game
over to rooks and the bishop against
tonight but more if you thought I okay
we were just gonna play rogue g2 no
point calculating this nasty line but he
allowed the Queen
caPSURE Sanji - from 11:00 thought we
have Bishop TRS and g2 and now rook H
captures on f6 so here morphe has to
decide what to do problem is if you keep
the Queen with Queen age 5 let's say
rook captures an f1 Bishop captures b6
it's it would be very hard to play
against these pieces because you don't
have a way of removing that for example
the dark square bishop you don't have a
beep on you don't have a deep on and you
only have a light square bishop so this
Bishop is immortal for the rest of the
game and with it being placed on such a
such a nice diagonal it will not be easy
to defend and the the knight is a tricky
piece also there's the rook it will not
be easy to play against this and morphe
agrees he decides to go into this end
game so Queen captures and f6 rook
captures rook captures and now he's just
up in exchange which as you've seen in
the previous game it is not a problem
for morphe to convert but let's see how
he does so tonight g4 goes after the
rook rook f5 now attacks the bishop and
b6 and ok like we said this bishop
nothing is touching this bishop so it
could have some the login for could have
some ideas on how to save this game
perhaps bark a brush of d5 morphe
immediately threatens f7 and forces the
knight to go back 9 h6 we have looked
the f6 now attacking the knight again if
you move video lose the f7 pawn so King
g7 and now rook the c6 preventing the
King from from going deeper into the
game we have a 5 now it's a very very
good setup when you have a bishop
against the rook and rook the c7 now
again not allowing the knight to move so
king g6 here Lowenthal wants to play f6
to finally get rid of this target and
now King g2 more if he starts bringing
the King into the game we have f6 and
now King to f3 we have Knight to f5 and
now comes Bishop to e4 and this is a no
brainer for Murphy he's up material so
he knows that all all trades are only
only giving him more advantage
King g5 and now just trading here
captures captures and h4 there's now a
wall so the black King cannot approach
the pawn king g6 and now rook the c6
thing
okay if you go after the pawn I'm gonna
capture the f6 pawn but there is nothing
better so King h5 but now rook to King
g3 not allowing this capture and here
comes f5 more if he goes after the pawn
rook to f6 and here a very freaky move
f4 here Leventhal is hoping for rook
captures on f4 and then so he could play
Bishop to d6 winning the rook here
although it wouldn't really help all
that much more fee instead place keen
captures and he says okay if you
captured and you're just getting
checkmated with rook to h6 so long until
unable of course to recapture the pawn
he goes Bishop to f2 he has to play
something but now King e4 now morphe
just goes after the Queen side pawns
with Bishop to c5 and here morphe just
shows how well he understands the game
rook the five check with King captures
on h4 n now he gives up the rook for the
bishop because of course he will just
gobble up the pawns and then Queen one
of his pawns here after King to d5
Lowenthal resigned to the game and
another victory for Paul Morphy now I
mentioned that it was a three game match
however moves of the third game are are
not saved I've read several different
reasons on why why they weren't saved
some said that both of them played
played rather poorly so they decided not
to save it I've read somewhere that I
love until had a really promising
position not a promising position that
he had a drawer drawer position and then
he made a blunder and then morphe
offered the draw and then Lowenthal
accepted I've read that more if he won't
all of the three games but it's hard to
say there are so many sources and I I
mean I'm not able to decide which one is
correct I've seen some somewhere written
that
Lowenthal actually published a different
result than amorphous fodder published
and xi all said that the the game the
match and the two and a half half in
more fees favor whereas it was actually
three three to zero so it's hard to say
so basically what we can conclude here
is that more if you won the match his
first ever match against the chess
master hunger
honey aqua Blumenthal with either three
and a half to zero or two and a half to
half a point so that's that's what I can
tell you and it's really it's really a
shame I mean poor poor woman thought he
didn't know what he was up against he
thought he was just playing against a 12
year old boy well ok almost 13 it was
almost his birthday but I mean imagine
if you played someone like that and then
one day they tell you okay yeah you know
the guy who played yeah he's just the
most talented chess player who ever
lived so it was definitely tough as he
was a renowned master and this results
the result of the game the match was
published so probably didn't go all that
well for for poor a Lowenthal but I mean
it's it's what it is a lot of people had
this happened to them when they faced
murphy which you will see if you
continue following this saga so now also
i've read that the the match the two of
them played of course the match but it
was also followed by a friend of
Murphy's father and the Murphy's uncle
so three of them were watching the match
and they said that whenever morphe made
a move that woman thought it was like
like he he really understood how how
strong do the moves were but yeah that's
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
not really sure where we're gonna take
the saga from now but you know that's
that's also one of the one of the joys
of enjoying the Paul Morphy saga you
have to also expect what the next video
will be about so there's that but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank the eros love Kirk
of landshort
around McVeigh Carl Schemmel and the Joe
Copco for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the of the
Murphy saga whenever I get the chance
for from the from the current events
that are being played in the in the
world so I think you'll I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day